[Music]
and helping the community news submitted
by healthy living it's so hard sometimes
though a supermarket has set up talking
tables in his cafes to combat loneliness
Supermarket that's a sad [ __ ] City
the supermarket is a pretty depressing
place the cafe inside a supermarket like
that like a Starbucks inside of a target
exactly that's a sad sad City that's a
sad place the Starbucks inventory bored
sad if they're talking to people wait
yes we asked his men one question oh he
was talking to us for a solid century he
worked at the library part of the
Huntington Library it's called the
Huntington Library so we wanted to see
if there was any books you can look
through but it was just like all in just
wait kind of thing it's a private
library it's not a public library so you
can't actually know we went up to him to
find out about this and then he just
would not let them it was like a simple
question like very sweet old man it was
something like this is like oh can we
rent the library like the books here it
could have been like oh no you can't and
this simple but it turned out to be well
what I went to Yale yeah and I when I
was younger oh by the way what do you it
was very he was like nice yeah it was so
cute she ran away and left us with the
for a fossil you didn't want to sit
there and take it I was listening to it
cuz it was all echoey and I still wanted
to look at all the things yet TIFF just
booped him on the nose and laughed so
[ __ ] cute like the nineteen fifties
like I gotta tell you that I that we
stood there just because you know what's
such a nice guy you probably just get to
talk a lot of people but at the same
time this girl and I was trying to laugh
so hard I just kept look cuz he was
looking right at Casey Casey was right
here and then it was me and David facing
each other all day while he was talking
mostly at Casey and the whole time I was
like
in case you towards the end of it he
could say like all right well thank ya
hey you following it that's amazing
that's [ __ ] sad we had to get out of
the conversation at some point back in
the mat quest days I remember like
asking people directions cuz [ __ ] gets
[ __ ] up it was always wrong it was
always a [ __ ]
and I remember and then if you missed a
turn you were [ __ ] like you can't you
can't get back to your directions on the
paper and then [ __ ] California people
you'd be like hey there how do I get to
this place anyway well you want to do
take take the five the 604 wait nope you
want to go to the 102 it's you don't
flip it all around California he's a
Virginian alright you leave him alone I
am a Texan
I'm by birthright I was conceived in the
great state of Texas the Lone Star State
is a great estate you were not couldn't
you or not everything's bigger in Texas
nobody will [ __ ] claim you unclaimed
in I'm also from in Virginia from from
all the worst states by them what are
you talk about is better than Sacramento
Indiana is tight first of all you keep
oh I get it's arriving it's a rivalry
she lived in those Salvation Army mom
protection homes yep there's so much
backstory to this he just completely
screwed it up and we're gonna get
completely off course so let's let's get
back on course so this story here it
takes place in the UK and so they have
this gross this supermarket called
Stansbury's supermarket and popular huh
and so they have design designated some
tables and they're cafes where people
can walk up to them and have
conversations with some employees in
case they're like really lonely God for
the employees feel about that well
I gotta work they're supportive they
want to help the community well of
course they're gonna say yeah they're
working there who's gonna say no I know
so this is some of the tables and then
this is what it says reserved for
customers in the mood for it well the
customers can talk to each other
together talking in text messages like
literally not if you live near this can
you take a picture of a guy just sitting
there a long waiting for someone that
said opposite him cuz that's incredible
there's like yeah that's a stock corner
for it come on man presenting it to the
team that has actor to actor did you
guys used to go in chat rooms back in
the AOL day yes form there's only one
person trading in there I [ __ ] go oh
I'm gonna wait till there's [ __ ] a
full room the best [ __ ] was going into
the AOL sex chat rooms and having a pre
typed paragraph so it's like ASL and
then it's like hey 14 female California
you cuz I was like 15 [ __ ] and then
they're like oh yeah I'm like forty-one
male like live in Florida whatever am i
okay and then they'd post me some [ __ ]
like yeah I'm rubbing my [ __ ] and then I
would paste this paragraph that said
like my name is Fred Phelps one with the
Federal Bureau of Investigation's laughs
my [ __ ] ass off the tongs crying it
was so [ __ ] amazing
it's like has left the room has left the
room control dude and I usually this
thing when I played this game called
team fortress classic the first one I
was like in a clan and shadows a [ __ ]
real loser and but I used to do this
thing where people like hey like people
new people were like hey how the [ __ ] do
I like do this thing where I can get the
hood off the thing or whatever and I was
like oh just hit control-alt-delete
three times fast and then you just see
like that's what became has left the
game that's the key
happen to you and you've been duped cuz
that's the story I want to hear Robin do
oh he never big boobs I don't know I
mean no I'm good you cannot do pit is a
bit he'll never tell us if it does
happen no I would be happy to okay okay
wait here's the best he has the best one
that happened on camera the best one
that happen our camera okay this guy
Greg for mediocre films I was still in
my real life trolling in Venice Beach
and he comes up to me and like Pat me on
the children's like what's up buddy and
all the [ __ ] and I guess he was putting
Bologna on my body the whole time and I
did not know and I wasn't sure what the
bit was so I was trying to go with it
but I wasn't sure what the bit was and
then I found out that he layered me with
Bologna that was and I think that's kind
of shitty well happy with your is that
want to hear okay you want to talk about
Steve likes to brag about this
colorblind [ __ ]
okay yeah so before we were together I
would I had him and Michael Gallagher of
shoulders guys convinced that I told
jokes in bed I did stand-up bits in bed
it was because we would do these q and
A's and they would always ask sex
questions and I didn't want them to know
about my sex life this was a different
time and I didn't want them to know
about my sex life I was like that's none
of their business they were jerking off
to it that would be like oh I always
like to tell some jokes you know get the
mood going and so then they were like
roasting me about like oh you're just
going to a stand if it but like yeah
like people like it it's cool and like I
would just do it and every time I saw
them it would be like how's daily life
you tell some good bits in bed and I was
like yeah I tested out some stuff and
like I don't know they were doing pretty
well but I had him going for years
yeah then we finally got all great for
it I thought funniest woman in bed here
we go I've never been more disappointed
about
it was so funny because every time they
would try to chill man they thought they
were like really get anyone over there
like they're like a whole you tell ya
you tell some pretty good joke so [ __ ]
stupid all over my [ __ ] face right
now so then we will when we went to hook
up and then it was like would be like
are you getting a [ __ ] hey where's
the joke sad girl hey I'm waiting for
the joke I was like this isn't very
hilarious [ __ ] but the thing is that
it wasn't about the bat bit it was about
how they thought that they were trolling
me so hard and I just didn't get with
that word they were making fun of me
about really one of those things where
you know somebody but you really don't
know what to talk about cuz you don't
know them that well so you kind of
always bring up the same bit because you
don't know what else they were like
making fun of me and I was like well
yeah that's great
that's when he came with the color blood
thing oh baby that came late way later
but but you know obviously my story is
not as funny as that one well I don't
pitch it while laughing so that's why
it's not I get you right not as funny
cuz I would laugh me what you talk about
yeah Thank You Sookie I you can't dupes
teve green I'm sorry I just miss a Olaf
very difficult I used to do the Eminem
voice chat
they had a voice chat room you could
hear people's voices I was in there on
eleven hours a day whoa 11 hours a day
what the [ __ ] never during Lent I cut it
back to five hours a day
damn I wouldn't want your internet bill
baby wasn't cheap oh no I got in trouble
oh yeah I also gave our address out to a
guy cuz I thought we were in love
no you're one of those yeah but I
thought was like no this is legit and
then he came over and you're like that
was 14 days
you wanted crying about some girl like a
Brandon boy
[Laughter]
call myself out I call myself you said
it gets me when I call myself out I call
myself a [ __ ] Jesus that's like using
my own fire oh you were one of those
like I was 25 when I was doing this yeah
well no because we all know those kids
who will have burning phone phone lines
fern getting yelled at by the parents
let the guy that you give the answers to
well we didn't work out but but I was
convinced I was gonna go to Philadelphia
and find this guy and we were gonna do
you are the daughter that every parent
worries about doing because I didn't
have friends
[Music]